let me just tell you kind of the leadup
what happened in the leadup of Ukraine
war it the Ukraine war we were lied to
because we're told oh yeah this evil
Putin trying to take over Europe and
this is his first step to reestablishing
the the Soviet Empire and that you know
it's the same comic is that a lie yeah
it's the same comic book description we
were given of Saddam Hussein in Iraq
which we were just lied into a war and
yeah it was a slam dunk that he hit
weapons Mass destruction of course he
didn't and he had nothing to do with
terrorism and he was running the most
Progressive um nation in the midd East
it was a secularized nation it wasn't a
a theocracy he wouldn't let
people um you know say I will agree that
you know maybe in hindsight that was
that was a mistake but all then let me
let me tell you what happened the real
story behind what happened in
Ukraine and and let me go back to 1992
because 1992 the walls come down the
Berlin Wall comes down and gorbachov
does something very courageous he goes
to Tony Blair and George Bush and he
says I'm gonna allow you to do something
that nobody in the right mind would do
which is I'm going to remove
450,000 Russian troops from East Germany
and I'm going to allow you to unify East
Germany under NATO which is a hostile
Army but I want one commitment to you
from you you will never move NATO
further to the east James Baker who was
then Secretary of State famously said to
him we will not move Nato one inch to
the
east so then five years later in 1997 Z
big new brazinski who's the first of the
neocons comes along and proposes let's
move
NATO to right up to the Russian borders
we're into 15 ations okay and at that
time the the most important diplomats in
American history at that time were
George Cannon who was the architect of
the containment policy during the Cold
War he said if you do that you're going
to force you're this is crazy it's
insane Russia just lost the Cold War we
should be giving them a marshal plan and
integrating them into the the civilized
society the Western Society don't make
them an enemy don't treat them like
they're still an enemy it's going to
this is going to force a a a violent
military response from Russia if you do
that Bill Pierce who was then the
Secretary of of Defense threatened
Clinton that he would resign if they
went ahead with this plan because it was
so reckless and Bill Perry and Bill
Pierce is now the head of the CIA Bill
Perry who was the US ambassador Russia
at the time said the same thing why are
you doing this this is crazy so between
now and then we move NATO into 14
countries why do we move nato in because
when they when you move them into a new
country they have to sign a contract
that conforms all their weapons
purchases to Nato specifications which
means you have to buy the weapons from
North grman you know from our these big
US military contractors who profit from
war we move it that in the meantime we
walk away unil Lally from two nuclear
weapons treaties with Russia Russia
wants those treaties they're
intermediate range missile systems that
you know so that which destabilizes
Europe when we when we remove our
agreement not to fire missiles on Russia
then we put agis missile systems which
are nuclear capable in Romania and
Poland so the broad listen you know the
details and these details are but and
and and I'm not taking a side on this
but if there was any which a lot of
people aren't really Advocates of but
Trump if anything kind of and whether he
was a puppet or not whatever you believe
he kind of normalized the Russian
relationship kind of right by becoming
somewhat of a a friend of Putin's so
between that time and the time that
Putin there was no NATO movement between
the time after the Trump Administration
yeah well what we did is and we
overthrew the government of
Ukraine no he he came into Ukraine
before we threw overthrew the government
in 2014 usaid which is spent $5 billion
which is a front for the
CIA which everybody acknowledges went in
there and started a revolution called
the it's called the maid on Rebellion
where there was these protests that
ended with the overthrow of the elected
government of Ukraine that wanted to
keep Ukraine neutral yakovich wanted to
keep NATO neutral we wanted a pro US
Government so we went in there in 2014
overthrew their government and placed a
government and by the way a month before
the overthrow we now have tapes you can
go on the internet and listen to a
Victoria nulan who's the who's the head
of the ni H now the deputy director of
the state department uh choosing the new
Ukrainian cabinet that will be put in
place after the coup that was still a
month away so she knew the coup was
coming a month in advance and but who is
she to us she's us she's The Head of the
State Department she's now you know
number three in the state
department but she's been in the state
department she's one one of the you know
she's a ni she's the she runs the niacon
uh uh program which is you know
continual Wars so she goes she they we
then pick a new government the new
government comes in immediately begins
attacking the the people of dbas and
lugans who are Russians speaking ethnic
Russians they banned the Russian
language which was there was two
languages that were two official
languages Ukraine they ban that there
violence immediately erupts and they
kill 14 there's a Civil War and really
this war started in
2014 there's 14,000 think Russians are
killed and and Putin kept saying you're
killing our
people he's trying to get a peace
agreement they finally work out a peace
agreement called the Minsk Accords
Germany signs onto it France signs onto
it England signs onto it and Russians
sign onto
it zalinsky runs in 2019 as president he
runs he has one platform issue he's a
comedian and an actor which I'm not is
there anything wrong with that oh my
wife is is one of those okay all right
but he never had any political
experience right but he wins with 70% of
the vote why cuz he runs on a peace
platform I'm going to sign the Minsk
Accords as soon as he gets in there
Victoria Newan and the and the you know
Ultra nationalist which is a nice way of
describing the you know the people who
run that government
now um tell him that he can't do it he
can't sign it so he pivots and then um
and then uh Putin then says okay Putin
is now faced with this
problem the United States government is
now running the government of
Ukraine and he is frightened to death
that the US Navy is going to go into
flat of osto which is you know the
southern Port has been the Russian Port
it's only warm water Port Russia has for
347 years so he then goes right into
Ukraine cuz he's got I mean into Crimea
and takes Crimea without firing a shot
doesn't kill a single person cuz the
people of Crimea are ethnic Russian and
want him back on him in there Dumas and
lugans then
vote 90 90 to one 90 to 10 to join
Russia Putin says no I don't want you I
want Ukraine to be a functioning state
but let's sign the Min Accords and um
and they won't sign it so then he sign
he sends in
40,000 troops I'm almost done with this
it sends in 40,000 troops that is not
somebody who wants to conquer Ukraine
there it's a nation of 44 million people
all he wanted was us back at the
negotiating
table um zinski we will not help zinsky
negotiate so he goes to Israel and gets
naali Bennett and Eran in Turkey to
sponsor negoti ations and they go and
they work out a peace
agreement and pu they sign it in April
of 2022 Putin is withdrawing his troops
according to this peace agreement or he
starts withdrawing
them Biden sends over Tony Blair and
tells zinsky to rip up the peace
agreement now how do we know this
because all the negotiators are now
talking including Neftali Bennett and
you can look it up when you're on the
internet you say you spend a lot of time
look at his speech where he tells you
what happened the lead Ukrainian
negotiator this week came clean and said
yeah that's what happened oh you know of
course Russ Russia's been invaded three
times through Ukraine the last time so
is Russia the good guy in your mind no
no Russia it was illegal what Russia did
but we have to understand they don't
want this war we wanted the war so let
me
he